Film Courage: So let’s say there is a young
person in their car driving from Arizona to
Los Angeles, and you have a quick phone call
with them during this trip, what would be
your tough-love encouragement?
Harvey Mason, Jr.: They are coming here to
work as a music producer, songwriter?
Film Courage: Music producer or it could be
anything within the industry but just the
general foundation [of what you would advise
them]?
Harvey Mason, Jr.: It would be a pretty long
conversation, but I would start with saying
if you’re going to come to Los Angeles,
be prepared for how competitive it is.
There are so many people doing whatever it
is you want to do.
There are thousands of them already here.
There’s going to be another thousand of
them coming tomorrow and they are all probably
going to be better than you.
So when you get here, be prepared for that.
And figure out what you’re going to do to
get better than them.
Come here with the mindset of I’m going
to have to really bust my butt to make it.
Because a lot of people come here and think
“I’m so talented.
My parents think I can sing.
One of my teachers at my college said I’m
a great songwriter,” whatever…that’s
why everybody here is amazingly talented and
beautiful and handsome and whatever it is.
That would be my first bit of advice and then
the other thing that I would say is be persistent.
You can’t quit.
You can’t give up.
You have to prepare for the long haul.
It’s not going to be quick.
You’re not going to be able to come out
here and land an audition the first week you
get here or produce a song that goes on the
radio for years.
It could take you years.
Be prepared.
Question for the Viewers: What advice would
you give to an artist who wants to move to
Los Angeles?